[Música]
i
bienvenidos a la entrevista de france 24
desde glasgow escocia donde miles de
personas se reúnen para tratar de frenar
la crisis climática una de ellas es el
alcalde de tegucigalpa y candidato
presidencial en área sur a bienvenido a
la entrevista de france 24 gracias por
estar con esas ansias muchísimas gracias
varian es un placer estar nuevamente
aquí yo muy emocionado después de 7 koop
desde lima parís el acuerdo signatarios
tegucigalpa el acuerdo de parís
marraquech bone kathoey y chile madrid y
hoy aquí nos sentimos muy felices de
poder entender bien el tema de cambio
climático y tener esa gran
responsabilidad que nosotros los
alcaldes son los que debemos de asumir
las y no esperar que el papá gobierno
nos resuelva todos los problemas de
nuestra ciudad vamos a hablar un poquito
del rol de los gobiernos subnacionales
en un momento pero quería preguntarle
cuáles son los mayores retos que tiene
américa latina y específicamente
honduras bueno te voy a decir que somos
países con muy pequeñas emisiones
realmente de gases de efecto y madero
pero tenemos que trabajar en ellas
aunque sean muy pequeñas
los retos que hoy tengo como alcalde que
hemos desarrollado en 7 años 9 meses de
mi administración hemos desarrollado una
infraestructura en un relleno sanitario
tratamiento de aguas sanitarias que
vienen a ayudar mucho al tema de la
reducción de gases de efecto de
invernadero el tema de cambios de luces
le da luces normales anteriormente
mercurio sodio cobra hoy es convertidas
en luces led que ha venido a quitarle
gran carga al tema del medio ambiente
reducción de emisión de gases
el nuevo nuestro nuevo proyecto piloto
de bus eléctrico que dentro de unos días
vamos a hacer nuestra primera prueba
piloto nuestro sistema
estudios finales ya he dicho sea de paso
agradeciendo al gobierno de francia que
nos ayudó a la verificación de nuestro
estudio para el tema de teleférico
cabinas de transporte público de 10
pasajeros que va a venir a ayudar
más personas tanto en el tema del costo
de la vida como reducción de emisión de
gases como mejor calidad de vida hacia
la gente y que esto va a venir con una
gran lucha de día a día que hacemos los
gobiernos subnacionales los alcaldes que
estamos cerca de la gente que somos
realmente la democracia más cercana a la
gente donde en nuestros municipios en
nuestras comunidades la gente ahí nos
tiene que decir si estamos haciendo bien
o no las cosas porque ahí nos conocen y
nos tienen cerca un congresista un
presidente cuando va a estar cerca de la
gente realmente y somos nosotros alcalde
las personas que estamos cerca la
persona que debemos de demostrar los
alcaldes los cambios sin necesidad de
que el papá gobierno intervenga y no de
los instrumentos los ingresos para poder
desarrollar precisamente usted ha
mencionado como presidente de la
coalición de ciudades capitales contra
el cambio climático cc 35 que ustedes
van a ser los garantes del acuerdo de
parís cuáles son algunas de las
iniciativas sub nacionales que se están
llevando a cabo en los 26 bueno quiero
decirte mariana que tengo varios
sombreros uno de ellos enlaces en 35
ciudades capitales desde desde canadá
hasta argentina también soy
representante de la inc ley la
vicepresidencia de iclei de méxico
centroamérica panamá y el caribe y
también soy el vicepresidente de la siss
de las ciudades y vero capitales de
américa tenemos que seguir trabajando en
el programa en lo que creemos nosotros
que hacemos todos los días como alcalde
yo creo que tenemos una gran oportunidad
y una gran transformación que podemos
lograr dios mediante este 28 de
noviembre tendríamos tenemos la
oportunidad de poder administrar el país
todas estas experiencias a nivel local
llevarlas a nivel nacional que es un
gran reto donde debemos de trabajar de
la mano con 298 alcaldes el reto el
tiempo se acaba blasco pasa muy rápido
venimos a hablar mucho durante mucho
tiempo pero debemos de estar bien claro
nosotros
países o los países grandes los grandes
países deberían de estar bien claros los
billones y billones que cuesta la
transformación para poder lograr este
cambio climático estamos dispuestos a
hacerlo mariana hay dos ventanas grandes
en el mundo una la ventana donde
recibimos todas las quejas donde
recibimos todas las protestas pero hay a
la par hay otra ventana también grande
donde dice un rótulo
estamos dispuesto a cambiar nuestro
estilo de vida para el cambio climático
la primera una fila inmensa de quejas y
la segunda muy muy muy corta la fila
entonces estamos dispuestos a cambiar
nuestro estilo de vida para el futuro de
nuestras próximas generaciones esos son
los gran reto que tenemos pero ella no
puede esperar y por eso desde
tegucigalpa los cambios que hemos hecho
en general han sido para venir a
fortalecer todo nuestro futuro de
nuestro país precisamente el cambio
climático o más bien la crisis climática
en la que estamos
afecta a todos los ambientes de nuestras
vidas vemos en centroamérica como
muchísimas personas migran hacia el
norte del continente para buscar una
vida mejor porque su manera de vivir su
manera de subsistir ha sido truncada por
el cambio climático por las sequías por
ejemplo en honduras es un grave problema
usted tiene un plan para detener estos
flujos migratorios no se puede contar un
poquito acerca de esto se vuelve se
vuelve en dos en dos lados uno cuando
tenemos sequías que nos convierte en un
país
extremadamente con muchas prioridades
especialmente en la agricultura en
nuestra sostenibilidad de para nuestros
alimentos y dos que es el otro lado
inverso es por ejemplo los huracanes que
acabamos de vivir el año pasado toyota
que nos han dejado un daño en nuestra
infraestructura pública y en nuestra
infraestructura
productiva pero extremadamente
gigantescos entonces como somos somos
unimos toda centroamérica es un istmo es
una línea cuando tú tienes un huracán
nivel 4 nivel 5 casi cubre tres países
entonces somos demasiado demasiado
vulnerables con dos océanos atlántico y
pacífico
que vienen a sumarse al tema de una
riqueza inmensa claro pero también una
desventaja para nuestros países el
trabajo que debemos de hacer es nosotros
contra la naturaleza no podemos pelear
debemos de mitigar los problemas y el
tema de cambio climático la crisis del
cambio climático registró cero sugirió
que era 2050 hoy 2040 yo creo que ese es
un tan poco tiempo en la historia que es
un parpadeo de ojos para poder nosotros
lograr los países del mundo entero los
seres humanos esa gran transición para
que podamos
ver de otra manera el cambio climático
de la amenaza mundial del cambio
climático entonces en las acciones no
son hoy no son ya debieron de haber sido
décadas donde agarrar la conciencia pero
quien la va a agarrar los grandes países
indemnizar a quien si al final dejamos
de existir a quién vamos a indemnizar de
que va a servir el dinero nosotros de
enfocarnos realmente en la naturaleza en
la sobrevivencia humana
usted está en plena carrera presidencial
queda menos de un mes para las
elecciones generales en honduras pero
sin embargo está usted aquí presente
representando a honduras
qué tan importante va a ser la agenda
ambiental si usted es elegido presidente
y por eso usted hable mariana desde un
comienzo desde la primer cop de lima
hasta hoy aquí que me siento muy
orgulloso en ocho años de gobierno
asistir a siete es un gran compromiso el
compromiso no es sólo venir y estar
frente a una radio o una televisión o un
periódico el compromiso tenemos que
sentirlos desde acá adentro nuestro
corazón en nuestra mente el compromiso
de nosotros de cada uno de los seres
humanos de cómo debemos de hacer y
especialmente nosotros los políticos y
los administradores públicos de que
debemos de hacer para el futuro de
nuestros países
es claro que si uno de ellos es zonas
protegidas en honduras para poder seguir
conservando nuestras áreas nuestra
producción nuestra producción de oxígeno
nuestra alta productividad en nuestra en
nuestro ambiente que debemos
y hacer conciencia en cada uno en cada
uno de los de los habitantes de nuestros
países para poder tener esa conciencia
cada vez queremos tener carros y
transportarnos individualmente tenemos
que tener un transporte público
eficiente que pueda seguro que pueda
darnos la oportunidad de reducir de
cambiar nuestra mentalidad yo creo que
los retos son muy grandes el tiempo es
muy corto pero si nos en forma
esforzamos mucho en enfocarnos nos
enfocamos y nos esforzamos con todo
nuestro corazón y nuestra mente ponemos
ese gran trabajo por delante estoy
seguro que podemos reducir todo estos
todos estos efectos del tema de cambio
crisis climático o sea que usted cree
que es su tiempo
en la gobernanza local y municipal le va
a ayudar a usted a poder ser un político
quizás más cercano a los problemas
reales de la población hondureña mariana
yo quiero decirte algo yo soy un
político no formado en política he sido
formado en mucho trabajo durante muchos
tiempos 45 años hacia atrás formado en
mi trabajo en lo que vale en el costo
del dinero en lo que se debe hacer en la
eficiencia que debemos de tener en lo
que debemos de cuidar nuestros recursos
entonces yo creo que la experiencia que
hoy he tenido como alcalde municipal en
estos siete años nueve meses si dios nos
da la oportunidad de administrar el país
creo que puede ser muy interesante para
continuar con esta gran agenda que hay y
por eso hice este gran en este gran
trabajo que me siento muy orgulloso de
estar aquí a pesar de que estamos a 26
días de las elecciones generales en mi
país estar aquí representando porque es
un compromiso no es un solo compromiso
con honduras es un compromiso con el
mundo entero de que debemos de ser
responsables ante esta gran crisis del
cambio climático y finalmente y
rápidamente le pregunto a honduras es
uno de los países más peligrosos para
los activistas y defensores del medio
ambiente cuáles son algunos de sus
planes si es elegido presidente para
parar esta matanza hay que darles la
oportunidad de a gente de poder
expresarse cada quien tiene que
expresarse para poder agarrar las
mejores ideas posibles todo todo
requiere un balance en la vida ninguno
de los extremos son buenos entonces
debemos de tener un balance debemos de
entendernos todos de buscar un punto de
encuentro para poder sacar adelante
nuestros países para poder sacar
adelante el mundo entero la seguridad de
la gente de la persona es lo más
importante nosotros debemos de
concentrarnos mucho en el tema de
equidad de equidad de género equidad de
raza equidad de lenguas equidad de todo
para que podamos tener un balance y ser
comprendidos realmente y poder
comprender a las otras personas y lograr
tener un mundo mejor donde podamos
heredarle a nuestros hijos pues con ese
mensaje energía segura muchisimas
gracias por haber estado con nosotros en
la entrevista de france 24 ya ustedes
sigan con toda la programación de france
24 en español
[Música]